NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LEYLA ISIK: So I'm
going to just go over
some very basic neuroscience,
mostly terminology, just
for people who have very little
to no neuroscience background.
When you hear the rest of the
talks, you would think like,
what does it mean that they're
talking about spiking activity?
Or what is fMRI measuring?
So that's like the
level at which this is.
So my disclaimers are one, like
I said, that it's very basic.
And two, that it will be
CBMM and vision centric,
because the goal is to
get you ready for the rest
of this course.
So please don't think that
this is an exhaustive,
or what I think
is an exhaustive,
summary of basic neuroscience.
So just to give you
a brief outline,
first we'll talk about
the basics of neurons,
and their firing.
Basic brain anatomy.
How people measure neural
activity in the brain,
both invasively
and non invasively.
And then a brief rundown
of the visual system.
This is a neuron.
And it has dendrites and
axons, and the signal
is propagated along
the axon, and the axon
terminates on another cell.
And when one neuron
terminates on another neuron,
they form what's
called the synapse.
So here are some pictures.
Sorry, it's hard to see on the
projector, of neurons synapsing
on other neurons.
And that is how
neurons communicate.
They send electrical
activity down their axon,
and it reaches the next cell.
And the synapse is both
an electrical and chemical
phenomenon.
We're not going to get
into the details of that,
but if you're interested, I
encourage you to Wikipedia it.
Neurons have a ion
gradient across them.
So there is a
different concentration
of certain types of ions
inside and outside of the cell.
And there are ion
channels along the cell.
And these ion channels
are voltage gated.
So what happens is when
these ion channels open,
the voltage inside
the cell changes,
and that eventually
leads a neuron to fire.
And they fire what is known
as an action potential.
So it's possible for neurons'
voltage to change a little bit,
and that is known
as potentiation.
So they can get either
excitatory and inhibitory
potentiation.
So that means either higher or
lower activity, as shown here.
And then once it reaches
a certain threshold,
they fire what's known
as an action potential.
So action potentials
are all or none firing,
and that's what is referred
to as neural firing,
or neural spiking.
It's this actual
spike in the voltage.
That is all you need
to know, like when
people are talking
about neural spiking,
they're talking about the
actual action potential.
But oftentimes, we're
not measuring things
at the level of single spikes.
So I'll get into
it in a little bit,
about what people are
actually measuring,
and what they're
talking about when
they're talking about
different recording techniques.
So some basic brain anatomy.
This is a slice of the cortex,
and just to orient you,
I'm going to put
these online, just
so you know the terminologies.
But there are different lobes.
The occipital lobe is
in the back, that's
where early visual cortex is.
Temporal lobe, parietal
lobe, and frontal lobe.
And if people are talking about
the inferior part of the brain,
they mean the bottom,
superior top, et cetera.
And this is a rough layout
of where different sensory--
can people see that?
Kind of, different
sensory and motor
cortexes, where they
land on the cortex.
So Nancy is going to give
a really nice introduction
to the functional
specialization of the brain.
This is just some
basic anatomical terms
to familiarize you all.
Right, so neural recordings.
So when we're talking about
invasive neural recordings,
the first type that we'll talk
about is electrophysiology.
So single and
multi-unit recordings.
And what that means is that
somebody actually sticks
an electrode into the
brain of an animal
and records their
neural activity.
So this can either
be a single unit
recording, which means you are
recording from a single neuron.
And either by sticking
the electrode inside or on
top of the neuron, or
very close to the neuron.
And that means that you're
close enough that you're only
picking up the changes
in electrical activity
from that one neuron.
But what's more
commonly measured now
is multi-unit activity.
That means that you stick
an electrode in the brain,
and it's picking up
activity from a bunch
of neurons around it.
So you can either
take that data,
and get what's known as
the local field potentials.
So that is the
changes in potential,
in general, in that
whole group of neurons.
And people often
analyze that data.
Or, you can do some
sort of preprocessing
to figure out how many
neural spikes you're getting.
So that's typically trying
to look at the neural firing.
So from that activity,
you can either
get the spiking pattern,
or what people refer to
as the local field potential.
And then you probably
heard, you will
hear a lot about ECoG data, from
Gabriel and others this time.
So this is really exciting.
It's the opportunity to record
from inside the human brain.
From patients who have
pharmacologically intractable
epilepsy.
So sorry this is kind of gross.
But when people are
having seizures,
if surgeons want to
resect that area,
they first have to
map very carefully
where the seizures
are coming from,
and what else is around there,
to make sure that they're
helping the patient.
So to do that, they place a grid
of electrodes on the surface
of the subject's cortex.
And then leave that
there often for a week,
for several days, while they
do different types of mapping
in that area.
So this provides the opportunity
for scientists like Gabriel
to then go and test the neural
activity in those humans.
Which is a very rare opportunity
to be able to record invasively
from humans.
And again, since we're on
the surface of the brain,
this is not single
unit activity.
So you get something that is
more similar to the LFP type
signal.
And then what I and many
other people in the center do
is also neuroimaging.
So this is noninvasive,
often in humans.
Although people also do
it in animals as well.
And the main types you'll
probably hear about
at this course are
MEG and EEG, which
are very similar,
and functional MRI.
So when many neurons
fire synchronously,
so the neurons in your
cortex have the nice property
that they're all aligned
in the same orientation.
So when they fire
at the same time,
you actually get a weak
electrical current.
And that electrical
current causes
a change in both the electric
and magnetic fields around it.
And EEG and MEG measure
the changes in electric e,
and magnetic m, fields
from those neural firings.
But it's usually on
the order of like tens
of millions of neurons
that need to be firing.
So we're now at a
much larger scale
than we were with the
invasive recordings.
And because the neurons all have
to be firing at the same time,
usually they're not all
firing an action potential.
Because if you remember, it
was just this very brief spike.
You're just measuring
kind of the changes
in the potentiation
of that whole group
of cortical neurons.
So this is a very
coarse measure,
but it's a direct
measure of neural firing.
So it has very good
temporal resolution.
So the question
was about, I don't
know if everyone heard,
the temporal scale of MEG.
So it's a millisecond
temporal resolution.
I think you can maybe
even get higher.
fMRI, on the other hand, usually
has a temporal resolution
of seconds, a couple of seconds.
But this spatial
resolution of fMRI
is on the order of
millimeters, whereas it's
more like centimeters in MEG.
And actually, so the
problem in MEG and EEG
is you're recording from--
here's a picture of the MEG,
scanner subject sits in,
and there's this helmet
that goes around their head.
And that helmet has 306 sensors.
If it was an EEG, they
would be wearing a cap.
You've probably seen
an EEG cap before,
and the electrodes would
be directly contacting
their scalp.
So you're measuring activity
from 100 to 300 sensors,
and often you're trying
to estimate the activity
in the cortex underneath.
And so that is on the order
of like 10,000 sources.
And so it's a very
ill posed problem,
meaning that there is
not a unique solution
to go from sensors to cortex.
And so because of that,
we don't actually-- that's
why they say that the
spatial scale is so poor.
But actually it's not
a well-defined problem.
So it's hard to even know where
the activity is originating
from.
But that's a very
active area of research
for how you can constrain
that problem with anatomy,
and other measurements,
to get better resolution.
But still, I think
people typically
think of it as being on
the order of centimeters.
So the other main type of
noninvasive neuroimaging we'll
talk about is functional MRI.
So here's a picture
of an FMRI scanner.
Subject's laying
there, and often
if we're doing a
visual task, they
look at stimuli on a mirror that
reflects from a screen where
we're presenting the stimuli.
So fMRI measures the
changes in blood flow
that happen when neurons fire.
And so as a result, this
is not a direct measure.
So this is not a direct measure
of the actual neural firing.
So it has a longer latency
for the blood flow effects
to occur.
And so that's why it has
the temporal scale that's
more like a couple of seconds.
But it has quite good
spatial resolution.
There's structural MRI,
which if any of you
have ever been injured,
you may have had an MRI,
and that measures the actual--
it doesn't measure
the blood flow,
it measures the actual
structures underneath.
I mean, often people will do
an MRI and a functional MRI,
and co register the
two, so you have
a very precise anatomical
image that you can then
put the brain activity on.
OK.
So I got into this a bit.
So invasive electrophysiology
is the highest resolution data,
both spatial and
temporally, I think,
that most scientists collect.
But it has some advantages.
One, that it's invasive.
So it's hard to test
questions in humans.
And just more
difficult in general.
And two, you're limited
by brain coverage.
So you can only stick
a grid or an electrode
in a couple of brain
regions at once.
So you really can't
get information
from across the whole
brain, at this resolution
with the technologies
we currently have.
fMRI, on the other hand, has
broad coverage and good spatial
resolution, but lower
temporal resolution.
And EEG and MEG have
high temporal resolution,
broad brain coverage, but
low spatial information.
All right.
So a bit about visual
processing in the brain.
So this is a diagram.
Can you see the colors?
OK.
A little, sorry.
Of roughly what people
think of as visual cortex.
So the blue in the back is
primary visual cortex, or V1,
that's the earliest
cortical stage that where
visual signals originate.
And then there is what's known
as the ventral stream, which
is often called
the what pathway,
or where people roughly believe
object recognition occurs.
And the dorsal
stream, which is often
known as the where
pathway, which is
thought to be more implicated
in spatial information.
However, this is an
extreme oversimplification.
I think Tommy put up this
wiring diagram the other day.
This is still a simplification,
but a more realistic box
diagram of all the
different-- each box
represents a different
visual region.
You can see that
there's connections
between all of them, between
the ventral and dorsal stream.
And while we roughly think
of it as feedforward,
which means that the input
from, the output from one layer
serves as input to the
next, often there's
feedback connections.
Meaning that information
can flow between areas.
So that's why it's been
so challenging to probe
with physiology.
OK, so like I said,
there are many layers
and they are thought
to be roughly organized
hierarchically into the first
level primary visual cortex.
In that area, you have
cells that respond
to oriented lines and edges.
So a cell will--
I'll show an example
of this, but fire
for stimuli that it sees, that
are in a certain orientation,
in a certain place.
And that is known as the
cell's receptive field.
And so it's often thought
of as an edge detector.
It's very analogous to
a lot of edge detection
algorithms in computer
vision, for example.
But then at what's thought
to be the top layer
of the ventral stream,
inferior temporal cortex,
cells fire in response
to whole objects.
And it's not just a specific
orientation that they like.
They will see this-- they
will fire whether they
see this object at
different positions,
and also have some tolerance
to viewpoint and scale as well.
So a lot of what we know
about the visual system
stem from Hubel and Wiesel's
seminal work in the 1960s,
looking at cells and cat V1.
This is the stimulus that
they're showing to the cat.
It's an anesthesized cat,
and they're recording.
So you'll hear a
popping, and those pops
are the neural activity
that they're recording.
[POPPING NOISES]
So they're recording from
a single cell right now.
So you see, you can
hear anytime they
present that light bar,
in that specific position,
the cell fires.
And then as soon as they
move it out of the bar,
the cells stop firing.
So that specific
cell really likes
this bar in this orientation.
And they called
this a simple cell.
We can fast forward
a little bit.
They also show, OK.
And then they found that there
are these other types of cells.
[CAR HONKING]
Sorry.
They showed that if you rotate
it, doesn't fire at all.
And then they show
that there were
these other types of cells.
This is maybe not
the movie we want.
There are other cells
that fire not only
to that specific position,
but to slight shifts
in that position as well.
And so it seems like those
cells formed an aggregate
over the simple cells, and
they called those cells
complex cells.
And then people did similar
things in mostly macaque IT.
And so they found
that in contrast
to simple lines and
edges, cells here
fired in response to hands.
So this is showing the
cells' response here.
So this is the number
of spikes over time.
So it fires a lot to hands.
And it fires to that hand.
This cell likes
that hand, no matter
what position you show it in.
But it doesn't like these kind
of other more simple objects,
and this one is not
selective for faces.
So in IT, there are cells that
are selective for very high,
you would think of as
high level objects.
And they're tolerant to
changes in those objects.
So people have done many
more sophisticated studies.
This is an example from
Gabriel and Jim DiCarlo,
and Chou Hung, where they
showed neural decoding.
So applying a machine
learning algorithm
to the output of many cells,
that these cells were again
very specific for
certain objects,
but invariant to
different transformations.
So in particular here, they
showed this monkey face
at different sizes.
And they showed
that the cell fired.
There was information present
in the population of neurons
for this specific
monkey face, regardless
of what size we showed it at.
So these cells are
often thought to be--
so it's often
thought that as you
move along the visual hierarchy,
cells become more selective.
So meaning, they like
more specific objects.
And more invariant,
so more tolerant
to changes in different
transformations.
And so the other thing
I wanted to talk about
was hierarchical feedforward.
So computational models
of the visual system,
because Tommy
mentioned this briefly,
and I think it will tie into
a lot of the computer vision
work you'll hear about.
So these are inspired by
Hubel and Wiesel's findings
in visual cortex.
So meaning-- and I'm going
to talk both about the HMAX
model, which is the
model developed by Tommy
and others in his lab
which is a simpler, more
biologically faithful model.
But this sort of
architecture is also
true of deep learning
systems that you heard a lot
about recently, and that
have had a lot of success
in computer vision challenges.
So if you have an
input image, you
can then have a set
of simple samples.
Again, these are inspired by
Hubel and Wiesel's findings,
so they are oriented
lines and edges.
So this cell will
fire, if you have
an edge that's
oriented like this,
at that part of the image.
And so again, it's just
a basic edge detector.
And so these perform
template matching
between their template, which
is in this case an oriented bar,
and the input image to
build up selectivity.
And then there
are complex cells.
And these complex cells pool, or
take a local aggregate measure,
to build up invariance.
And so what that means is if you
have, say this red cell here,
this complex cell would look
at these four simple cells.
So you are now selective
to that oriented line,
not just at this position,
but at all of these positions.
And that gives
you some tolerance
to changes in position.
So you'd be able to
recognize the same object,
whether it had this feature.
Whether it was presented at
this corner or in a local area.
And so the way
you do that is you
take a max over the response
of all those input cells.
And then you can repeat
this for many layers
and, it's essentially
the same thing
as a multilayer
convolutional neural network.
And at the end, in
this HMAX model,
you take a global max over
all scales and positions.
So, in theory, you have all
these more complex features
that you can now respond
to, regardless of where
in the image and how
large they're presented.